I think because I've seen it I've got a
stepdad and I've seen it in my house
where he's disciplined like my brother
who was acting up and needed a little
box around his head and wasn't told oh
my mum didn't come through like what are
you doing like it was just normal
because at the end of the day as much as
you're my stepdad you are the man in
this house you are the Father Figure in
this house yes we have a dad and yes we
see that but you are here so for me it's
normal it's not I'm not looking at it
like no you can't you can only do this
or you can only do that or yeah but
you're a little you are a little bit
because before when you were saying well
it depends what he's doing because but
that at the time my brother deserved the
box so that's why I asked it to you
because you just said it like oh if he
snaps what I'm depending on what happens
I'm I'm hoping that that situation was
deserved well yeah but what I'm saying
is in this situation you would disagree
but you like would you be able to if
he's he's disciplining your kid in a way
that you you don't agree with right and
you don't think it was necessary would
you be able would you be able to that's
that's the point
it's necessary to slap a child for
knocking over a cup but I'm saying like
but the point the point is being
submissive
the point the point the point is that
being submissive is relinquishing
control and giving the man control and
authority and being able to shut up even
when you don't agree yeah and so yeah
okay okay a cup I don't agree with that
I can't like what should I do allow my
child to get beaten well right but I'm
not saying beating up like you're going
to the extreme example flap for about
because that's why I can't keep my mouth
shut if it doesn't feel right as a
mother it's not going to happen but if
it's I'm I'm gonna allow you to be that
person in my house of course well the
the point is I mean you have to pick
wisely right the point is you do have to
pick wisely but when you do pick there
are going to be situations where you are
not going to agree and that man like
wants to have the authority and not have
you nagging on him being like Oh I don't
like that was wrong you can't do that
you can't do that like it's just shut up
and let them discipline the kids and if
you can't do that like that's why guys
don't date single moms
can I ask a question we kind of straight
though we're talking about cheating
sorry you want to read super chance yeah
I was going to read Super Chat real
quick real quick and then we'll get back
into it okay guys as you know thank you
for the super chats because we are
trying to get ish a camera
so Chris a hundred dollar Super Chat
let's go
to the lady in the middle ma'am I am a
man who makes 100K a month and trust me
women like you don't intimidate me using
the word intimidate is how women like
you cope with the fact that men don't
want to deal with you and only view you
as side chicks swell City
does she read or look at these super
chats
um
um okay uh Leia E when dating single
women with children does it make a
difference if the woman is a widow
um actually I'm gonna ask do you think
it makes a difference if the woman is a
widow oh good question yes yes because
why
because it's like competition I feel
like it's the same no it's not because
there's no competition
I just feel like um it's like she did it
the right way she got married had the
kid is that why yeah you know it's not
as indicative of a pattern of behavior
that resulted in no longer being married
all of their control yeah Sarah do you
think it's different if the girl's a
widow
um I think it is because you no longer
have to deal with
um the actual biological father I think
it actually is a bit different okay Elia
Ewan dating
um oh wait I did that one DJ wolf hey
Pearl your videos made my 12 hour drive
a breeze thank you
um Dragon stallion1001 sorry but no man
wants us to spend their resources on
raising another man's kids Rider it
becomes mod it's because modern women
don't need men they can leave
relationships over not feeling happy
King Gill gamash if women only want men
and not need them men think that
tomorrow you could want someone else men
think long term will you not want us in
20 years we cannot guarantee that you
won't want us tomorrow can I answer that
go ahead if I want you I chose you so if
I choose you I'm not just going to
decide for no reason I'm not going to
want you no more I think you you have to
be secure in the situation that you're
in if somebody didn't you a little bit
but
as far as elaborate like when you were
talking earlier he's a good dad you said
he is he's a good provider doesn't mean
he's a good partner
it just it just does but I just I'm not
getting like a real good reason when I
was young I grew up people evolved
but see this is you're proving men's
point though
this is this is like their point is
there's no women change their mind like
to win man like it's just it's just you
can have the most
perfect perfect situation and still say
and then once you get like I said once
you get out into the dating market and
it goes tits up then you're up you're
upset you're angry you're bitter these
men these men are trash these men are
this it's like you had a good situation
love like you you left to somebody
else's perspective to the outside world
it may look like the ideal situation but
only you know what true happiness is for
you right all right when you are in a
long-term situation like I said you
evolve and you grow right so if you're
not both evolving and growing at the
same Pace sometimes you feel like that
person is holding you back a little bit
in life but but marriage is the choice
of saying I'm gonna put this and I know
you guys weren't married but typically
like a 15-year relationship I think you
may as well have fun
but it's putting the family above my
personal happiness and Duty above
happiness and so that's why like like
that would be a red flag to guys and I
could I can respect that right and that
just wouldn't be the right guy for me
and my point in saying that is the end
of the day I did sacrifice everything my
own happiness for my family but when you
get to a point where you are literally
depressed and you're upset and you're
crying every day and you don't know why
you're crying and all of these things
are happening and you don't feel
supported as an individual you do have
to sometimes make a sacrifice I am
happier like I have a good he is a good
dad so I'm lucky in that way that my
children haven't necessarily lost out
completely you've been broken up for
long
um a year
so I have a I have a question I have a
question
um
um how old did you say you were
um I'm fatty Che so if you were 42 and
you didn't find anyone else would you
still feel the same way
as far as like like if you were still
single at 42 would I still feel the same
way about leaving my about leaving
um or let's let's actually you know what
it's 52 62. would I regret oh my God why
would I be single with that
you're not a time one at a time because
it's gonna be hard with as a single mom
with three kids um and this is where the
contradiction comes in I'm not being
funny if I can accept when I initially
first initially was like yeah I did
actually go through a stage where I was
like I want to be celibate I don't want
to give myself abstinent let me say that
because sometimes dreams is like Nas you
know okay absent I decided I'm gonna you
know refrain from being sexually active
with somebody from dating them and
um I decided to do that so that I can
really go into a situation with fully
like my whole you know being like
mentally emotionally spiritually
everything involved
day in now compared to when I was with
my ex I was a different person I'm
emotionally evolved now I understand
what real love is I'm not now accepting
toxic Behavior as a form of love because
I've now discovered who I am so then the
person that will get me at 40 years old
at 50 years old is getting a different
version than he had when I was 18 20
years old but but it's a it's a less
valuable version to me um that's not the
right man for me because it's not the
right man for you it's how much like men
can't help but they're attracted to no
it is all man but they can't if you
survey men if you survey a man between
the ages of 20 and 80 they're all the
most attracted to 22 year olds I peaked
three years ago and
and and and you guys did too whether you
yeah whether like at 20 22 23 and and
this is men between the age of 20 and
80. so what men value is Purity Youth
and fertility and so like what would you
be able to offer to a guy
if you can't hear what a man that's
looking at 20 year olds saying
about those 20 years no at 50. if you're
50 and you're saying oh okay and I'm 50
and you're gonna turn around and tell me
oh I'm I want somebody that's 20 years
old or okay are you would you how old
are you I'm 33. would you be open to
dating a 50 year old not right now okay
but that's that's the problem so if you
don't know if you don't if you don't do
if you don't do an age because the 50
year old may not want a 22 year old but
they do want a 32 year old but if you
don't give the 50 year olds a chance the
guy's your age are looking at the girls
my age that's right
I'm 45.
do you ladies seriously think that 32
year old men are looking at
32 year old women nope no I don't we've
used with children yeah
I
think I can
I do know if you remember are like okay
I'm 41.
I'm 41. yeah and I know that worst case
scenario
best case scenario I can get someone
who's 25 right at 41. worst case and get
someone my own age right women when they
hit 41
the the same options are not open like
and if a woman is 41 and she's getting a
25 year old we already know what that's
for do you know I mean it's not for any
kind of long-term you know partnership
like so so 25 year old this with the 41
year old is for a long-term partner yeah
I would I would I would date I would
date afford it would be more attracted
to older men yeah 100
mature dude's got a massive Advantage
like he knows how to act he's learned
from his mistakes but what happens when
she goes more established in life when
these women here were 16 yeah when these
women were 16 the 16 year old boy is
their age you never had no pocket money
we're not attractive today remember that
the 19 year olds who had their stuff
together I did the older boys yes
what did you say what did you just raise
different I wasn't looking at them
no no no no but in general oh guys guys
one at a time one at a time please thank
you very much go ahead go ahead in
general I know that is a thing because
now if you look at it obviously doing
podcast lives and stuff people talk to
us and be like Oh yeah I remember when I
was in uniform and my guy was coming to
pick us up so these big men were coming
to school to pick up the little girls to
say okay look so I know I'm not naive
but it just not not my heart but when
50 of your options are gone by 30. even
if you undate according to dating app
data so and that's without that's
without children
so if you add a kit on that it's like
smaller and smaller and smaller pool and
that's from that's right yes and so and
that's why that's why Kevin Samuels
always said you don't get better than
your baby daddy
oh that's such an interesting point and
can I just asks then is it more likely
did you finish that's okay well finished
um is it more okay quick question is it
more likely that a woman that has
children and is past the age of 30 is
likely likely to get cheated on
yeah because you have less Leverage
like so so okay say I'm 20. I'm 25 right
if I'm dating a guy for two years let's
say I get married to him right no no
kids yet I I can leave and go get it go
get someone else but every every year
you wait the older you get the less
options you have so I gave my best years
to my children's father Yes but I don't
understand
but I don't understand the shock though
I think I think it's like I feel like a
lot of things but reality is different I
feel like I'm 120 pounds
but reality is different it just kind of
drives home that that woman like someone
living in such a different reality yeah
that the idea of these things are like
shocking well I think for a man it's
like really Common Sense yeah I have
this a lot where you know in in the
social scenes I'm in there'll be one
gorgeous girl and she'll she'll be great
at the start she'll maybe get with two
or three of the top guys
and then you know she'll realize I'm a
cool dude and she now thinks I'm gonna
take home four dates and have a serious
relationship with her and she's actually
shocked that I won't like honest to God
her face is like eyes wide open like I
can't believe this it's very yeah it's
very interesting say something is that
because into John's Kevin Samuels again
you look women don't necessarily look at
their tear so what I've noticed with
some of my female friends is that when
they're stating all these things like
the six foot one this the salary that
I'm like well I'm go what are you doing
like what are you bringing to you know
the classic to the table I am the table
you're not though you're not bringing
something to him to suggest that you're
of that level to be eligible to date
that man but you still think that you're
worthy of dating that man but you're
gonna drain all their resources and then
do it in the name of oh but I I want
that that's that to me that's that's
where
well that's why Kevin would say height
weight dress size height weight dress
size that's your starting point and then
what do we like each kid subtracts two
points
this is science yeah so is that like
you're dating within your sorry dating
within your tears so as in you know
you're within your lane if you're in in
a similar Lane and obviously as you
mentioned men always would like not
always but typically men would like to
have some um authority over there well
that's fine or be someone at a higher
rate but you you still need to look
within what is your category you can't
be a Fiat 500 and I'm looking at home
I'm feeling like yeah feeling hard done
by because unfortunately that's not your
bag unlike the problem is though
or a problem is that when you have a
group of guys who hit the club and
there's one guy in the group he doesn't
do as well with the ladies as the rest
of the group after the guys are finished
teasing him if they're really he's Bros
yeah yeah they'll pull him aside and
they might give him a couple pointers
and say you know what bro you might want
to switch this up you might want to
switch that up that's what Bros do yeah
what the sister code is is you just
ain't met the right one no no no no no
no that's true
yeah
it is not it is not right um you know
what maybe the reason why we all get
attention from guys and you don't might
be a you problem maybe you need to
change something about you no we don't
generally that's not what we do let's be
real we don't do that we we we make
oursis feel good and we say babe he just
ain't make the right one for you let's
be real yeah I did a whole show we
talked about fat phobia and people and
they're saying that fat girl girls
deserve love nobody deserves love no no
but I'm saying just like short broke
guys don't deserve nobody deserves love
you get what you deserve as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible